nowy unijny podatek winduje ceny ogrzewania
analitycy policzyli już
że średnio gospodarstwo roczne emituje w polsce 6t co 2
przy stawkach podatku ets
który ma wejść w życie OD 01.01.2027
czyli przy stawce €45 za tonę
to jest kwota zł1.200 na każde mieszkanie
właściciele mieszkań
lokali domów
którzy mają ogrzewane je węglem
eko groszkiem
olejem opałowym czy gazem
nawet oni wszyscy zapłacą duże pieniądze za idfikse
które i tak nie zmieni rzeczywistości
Unia Europejska imituje zaledwie 7% emisji
co 2 do atmosfery
zatem to i tak Nic nie zmieni
za to zwykłych ludzi
doprowadzi to do ruiny
a gospodarkę europejską
w tym polską gospodarkę
do o wiele mniejszej konkurencyjności